跳空缺口怎麼看
今天朱老師要給你
滿滿的一堂課喔
區式上大概分這四個位置
四大缺口
左一則陶藝缺口
或兩側缺口就是
它已經走一波了
你要判斷一個缺口
力量夠不夠大
你就用這兩個去看
把缺口學會
你會找到很多機會
這種跳空缺口就是
主力發動
是一個很重要的訊號
人家給你答案號了
對啊
怎麼樣缺口容易長
割頭確認的缺口
從這以後比較做多
如果
第二天開盤就跳工
你今天可以進場
像撐竿跳 跳高
看到了這個位置跟這個位置
都是很容易漲
好明確喔
所以你看得懂 你要趕快進
趕快進
你不要怕
朱老師 在連假的時候
因為你休息嘛
沒有來錄影
有網友就留言說
他要退訂
因為你不在
怎麼可以
對啊
不行的
然後他們就問為什麼你搞失蹤
搞失蹤
對
搞失蹤就是讓大家緊張一下
為什麼要讓大家緊張
要緊張才會再來找我
對
所以你以前談戀愛會搞失蹤嗎
應該沒有吧
這個對方失蹤
對方失蹤嗎
對
那通常對方失蹤
女朋友失蹤的話
下一步如果說出現了
那到底是力多還是力空
不曉得
後來都沒出現
都沒出現
這個很嚴重
那是跳工跌停鎖死就對了
最後找到一個不失蹤的
就是一個結婚的對象
因為我們今天要講跳空缺口
但是不是每次搞失蹤
都是不好的結局
有時候復合以後感情更好
對
那這是大概有計畫的失蹤
故意讓你掏心後悲就對了
讓你緊張一下
好 我們今天講缺口啦
好 我們今天的
理財大臨秀標股在現登
大家一直在問 哇 朱老師還會來嗎
還會來 不要擔心
因為朱老師要挑戰骨魚的地位
就是沒有三十級是不會下崗的
而且可能會更多
朱老師想有這樣講嗎
然後呢 今天要講什麼
講剛剛講的 搞失蹤
什麼搞失蹤
股價有時候搞失蹤
在線圖上出現一個缺口
它可能往下有所謂的跳空缺口
網上也有跳空缺口
可是這個缺口是不是都是不好的
不是喔
有時候搞失蹤完
你的股價更強勢
你的女朋友 男朋友更愛你喔
那趙華呢 大家可以看到
有沒有 今天腿上有個歐車
然後剛剛找粉底一找不到
這個也是因為去爬山的時候
有跳空缺口摔倒喔
不是罰貴罰的喔
所以跳空缺口怎麼看
今天朱老師要給你
滿滿乾貨的一堂課喔
好 我們來看一下
這個股票在走的中間
我們常常會看到缺口
其實缺口很容易看
就中間空的
空了一塊嘛
那缺口 對
我們看一下聯發哥最近很紅
那因為這裡跑了一個缺口出來了
對 這邊是往下疊的時候一個
這是往上的
那其實你一看就很清楚
你看往下它就下來了
對 往上它就上去了
所以這個缺口就有所謂的
其實趙華剛剛說缺口有好有壞
在我們學技術分析
就沒有什麼好壞
為什麼呢
往下做空啊
喔 那都好啊
對啊 妳只要看懂了都可以賺啊
所以妳想分手它失蹤
在
妳想常報它出現也在
如果它要失蹤我就換一個
往誰做好事
說出來了喔 對不對
好 那這樣子我們就知道
把缺口學會
妳會找到很多機會
因為我們學技術分析
就在找機會 是
所以往下有往下的機會
往上有往上的機會
那到底為什麼會出現缺口
可能很多入門者還不知道
為什麼 我們也看一下台積電
你看台積電供的時候
它就一直用跳空缺口
三天上漲就有兩個用跳空的
就出現了這個跳空缺口
它出現缺口是因為漲很急嗎
就是為什麼會有這種空洞的
我們最重要的
我們先把缺口的定義講一下
好 我們把定義講一下
不然大家不知道什麼
搞不清楚為什麼
那如果是向上跳空缺口
就是今天是往上走的
可是中間留了一個空白
那這個空白就是沒有人成交
沒有人成交
對 我們都知道股票是每個人都在掛價
你掛高一檔 我低一檔買
然後成功的就可以搓合
你就會發現為什麼今天一開盤
昨天80 今天一開就83
而且後來就沒有再下來了
那中間他有三塊錢跑哪去了
沒有成交 就沒有人成交
這你沒有人交易
這個地方沒有人交易
就叫做一個向上的跳工缺口
他向上是指說
這個太平易也沒人要賣嗎
對 也沒有
所以買不到
就也沒有買不到
你要82塊也買不到
對 人家沒有
那很強耶
對 所以這個往上的就很強
那所以我們如果出現一個
挑戰功力缺口
各位先記好這四個位置
就是你上面這個K線的高點
還有這個低點
還有下面K線的高點跟低點
那我們的缺口就是
上面的最低點
減掉下面的最高點
對
所以這個是缺口
就是沒有成交的位置
那反過來就懂了嘛
是往下疊的
往下疊也沒有人敢在這邊買
也沒有人買
然後這你就沒有成交價
這是一個往下的跳空缺口
那這個缺口也是一樣
這個叫缺口的下沿
這個叫缺口的上沿
因為缺口以後也會
日後他也會出現變化
那這時候這些位置就很重要
看他有沒有出現一些變化
所以朱老師如果沒有成交
像往上的話就代表賣的人很習受
所以他很強
可是跌的話就等於買的人也縮手
他很弱
所以缺口有這樣的意義
所以我們向上就表示很強
向下就是很弱
那我們現在為什麼會跑出一個缺口
怎麼會這樣請您
大概有兩個狀況
一個就是利多利空
利多利空的消息大概都反應一到兩天
再來還有一個最重要的
我們比較重要就是主力的
這個跳空是主力發動的
是
股價今天主力要抬了
要拉抬了
他就用跳空的拉
也就是說讓你買的人
你買不到低價
你要就來追高
是 對不對
那主力在上面出貨了
他可能用跳空就殺
當天開低就殺盤
所以這個對我們來說比較重要
因為利多利空我們沒辦法掌握
對不對 那個消息也不知道
晚上出來還是什麼
那我們看一下美股
這是利空的
美股在3月12號晚上跌了快10%
3月12號
各位可以回去看一下
就是今年一個大跌盤
對 800多點快1000點
那我們第二天就完了
我們一開百就一個大利空
因為我們美股是國際盤
國際盤如果是跌得太多
就會影響我們
就會出現一個利空
可能小張小跌還不會
但這種超大的一定影響
一定影響
好 其實各位再想一下
前一陣子川普不是說宣布得
得到新冠肺炎
我們台股第二天就會跌
就會開低
因為這是一個利空
而且他的跌幅比較大
如果他們只是一兩百點
可能玩音樂還好
就不會有影響
好 那我們再來看
這也出來一個跳空缺口
老師有特別強調
是主力發動的缺口
這是主力發動的
主力發動的
我們先來看一下
股價盤的這麼久
也沒人買
你看上面都沒有量
全部都沒人買
可是在這一天
就有人開始買了
買了以後
主力用跳空跳空的
那在我們一般的散戶
你都不太敢追
因為他用跳空
本來你看到第二天想買
可是第二天他一開就很高
你又縮手了
你又不敢買
我說怎麼那麼高
等一下第一點再買
然後他就沒有了
他就沒有低價
然後第二天一樣開高走高
等到你有想要有低價了
就在這裡
結果你買在高點
那這種開始發動的位置
就是上漲 旗漲的位置
這種跳空缺口就是主力發動了
所以這種缺口對我們來說
是一個很重要的訊號
是主力有表態
就是我要拉 對
他要拉了
所以你看得懂
你要趕快進 趕快進
你不要怕
人家給你打暗號了
對啊 主力會給你暗號的嘛
所以你學技術分析
就是懂得主力給你的訊號
是
你就可以趕快進場
好
這是主力的
這對我們最重要
好明確喔
對 很明確啊
它是用跳空缺口的
是 所以老師要教我們看囉
我們要知道跳空缺口
有幾個特性
好 記住三個訊號特性喔
第一個是主力的強力的訊號
強力動能
那你要看位置嗎
我剛剛講如果高檔往下的話
這就是主力告訴你它跑囉
那也是強力動能
你叫趕快跑啊 對不對
如果盤整突破
這是主力告訴你我要突破啦
那你就趕快跟進
這是他的強力的
買進或賣出的訊號
那第二個
我們都在講K線嘛
我們前幾集有討論到
長紅長黑
可是如果你出現一個跳空缺口
就比這個長紅的力量還要強
哇塞 比兩個紅K棒
或是長黑K棒都要強
如果你往下的缺口
那我們就叫做你不能小看
他比長黑還要強
所以他的力量就會更大
所以等一下我們看圖
就會告訴你這個缺口出現
你要做什麼動作
所以光是一二
其實朱老師布廷的強調
缺口的動能非常大
比長黑長紅
對 都是非常
比他們還要強
所以出現我們真的要特別留留
這個訊號就更明確了
更明確
那第三個
我們看到的缺口
你就可以知道
應該是往上坐還是往下坐
因為他給你一個很強的上漲訊號
所以你叫往上坐
那給你一個往下殺的訊號
你就要趕快
趕快賣掉八股票賣掉
或者是你做空嘛
反手做空嘛
所以這些都在缺口
那個地方去發生的
我覺得有學到了
因為今天要做之前
那個製作人跳跳
就有問我說
姐 你會不會看到缺口的興奮
我說我還好耶
我說你不是在上軍線嗎
軍線多排還借老師講的
對 然後沒想到
缺口那麼重要
那就是一般的啦
比如說我們講多頭回後買上漲
可是他用跳空上漲
那就是強
那就很強啊
本來你不太敢買
這個更要買
因為主力告訴你了
我用跳空拉
很可能明後一天就
直接就拉上去了
所以在這些重要位置
你去去看一下
你就知道這個位置的強度
是
這個這樣強度
但老師缺口的名字
好像不是只有缺口
不是只有跳空跟上漲
他有在不同的股價位置
他還有不同的名字跟意義
那我們剛才講了
缺口
因為缺口在一個趨勢
行進中間 經常會看到
那我們剛才強調
大部分都是突破缺口
就是旗長的位置
所以你要趕快做
因為他是旗長
可是如果走到高檔
又出現缺口了
那就不一樣了
那缺口代表的意思不一樣
所以我們一個趨勢上
大概分這四個位置
四大缺口
四大 四個缺口
那位置不同 位置不同
名字也不一樣
第一個我們叫普通缺口
普通缺口
普通缺口就是這個缺口
沒什麼力量
普普通通
老師剛剛普通缺口
都是力量很大嗎
又有普通的就對了
所以我剛剛講缺口的位置
那這個在哪裡
就在盤枕區裡面
它在盤枕裡面
在盤枕裡的缺口
它突然今天可能有一個小利多
它就太高了
可是它沒有突破
它並沒有突破盤枕
那明後天它就又回來了
又補掉了
所以老師你剛剛講那個重點
對 缺口的大小也很重要對不對
當然 缺口如果小氣力量也比較小
缺口如果大力量也比較大
那你在盤枕區
你一直沒有突破盤枕
對 所以你有了缺口也沒什麼用
沒什麼用 我們在等突破
等突破那個缺口
抓到一隻沒有用的皮膚球
這個就叫普通缺口
那當然所以說你要看趨勢嘛
如果在盤枕裡面的缺口
你不要太興奮
不要趕快追進去
普 功力普
它是一個普通的
好 這個就最重要了
這個就叫突破缺口
突破缺口表示
它已經開始轉槍了 對不對
比如說軍線被突破了
壓力被突破了
盤枕被突破了
那這個就很重要了
所以這個缺口是叫旗掌
突破嘛
它在剛剛開始這個多方轉槍
所以這個位置是最重要的一個缺口
然後再來叫桃益缺口
桃益缺口
桃益缺口這個名稱看起來很奇怪
我們一般叫做量測缺口
測量缺口
涼測是涼東西的涼測嗎
測量或者叫測量缺口
那跟桃義也差太遠了吧
對啊 實際上是
你用這個字很難理解
等一下我們看讀解釋你就知道
所謂的桃義缺口或涼測缺口
就是它已經走一波了
它不是在這個位置
不是在低檔往上 對
它已經走了 比如說出生段
出生段走完了
就是要走主生段了嘛
可是它用跳空的
那是強的意思嗎
對啊 當然就是很強
主聲段也很強 比如說
出聲段完了 它進到盤枕
那這個地方的盤枕突破
它就叫逃逸缺口
它也叫突破缺口
它也叫逃逸缺口 逃逸缺口
但是位置不一樣 對 位置不一樣
如果你是底部打底的突破
那個叫突破缺口 是
它不叫逃逸缺口
可是如果你在出聲段結束完了
在空 對
那個跳空缺口就叫逃逸缺口
逃逸缺口的意思就是說
主力還要再供一波
因為他用跳空的弓
那大致上會跟你出身段
弓的幅度差不多
所以我們叫兩側
你大概還可以再量一段
再量一段上漲的幅度
上漲的幅度
好 那這個一看就完了
潔淨缺口
他也出了個缺口
對 那這個缺口
好像已經快要最後一個
這就叫潔淨
我怎麼知道他最後一個咧
等一下我們看現象就知道
潔淨缺口最大的特點
最大的特點
我們在這邊解釋一下
好 我們再來講得更清楚
一次高等四種缺口
我把剛才那個整理一下
普通缺口就在盤整區
它在盤整區
因為它沒有突破
所以它還是沒有這麼大力道
所以這個意義就不大
搜索嘛
我們看到了就看到了就好了
好不好
突破缺口是最重要
最棒的
股價遇到壓力了
盤整區的壓力它突破了
所以行情發動
向上突破 向下跌破
所以這個是我們旗掌起碟
旗掌起碟出身段或是出跌
這就我們剛剛講
你一定要趕快進場
肉最多的地方
因為你等了半天
結果等到它是突破的
而且用跳空的
那桃葉也叫測量
或叫中跡
也就是說它後面還要再走
那在這個地方
表示上漲下跌
還有一個更
還有一波
就是說它還有一波
那趨勢會繼續
我們可以測一下目標
所以等一下說我們
還有膠 這種之後會膠
預測物標講
不會再開一堂課了
就是說你在中間看到一個討益缺口
表示還會長
你就再繼續做
那捷徑缺口
剛剛講捷徑
還叫消耗缺口
沒有力量再供了
這個缺口反而沒力量了
那它會也大概都在行情的尾聲
所以大部分都在陌生段
或者是急長彎
它已經一直拉拉拉到最後
用跳弓缺口的
這個跳弓缺口
吐出一口鮮血就對了
很勉強
但是他會有一個現象
等一下我們也會這樣
也就是這個缺口出現
三天就結束了
他就反轉 行情下跌了
反轉訊號
而且這邊代表陌生或末跌段
那等於是說如果是陌生段
那我就反手作空
對 末跌段我就反手作跌
對 那就是缺口
可以讓你看得出來
他會長還是會跌
容易長還是容易長
照好都講得很簡單
圖拿出來辨認一下
我們放在圖上就很簡單
我們有講缺口一定要跟趨勢配合嘛
所以你在這裡是不是看一個缺口
這邊有一個
這是往下的嘛 往下的缺口
那你一看就知道這是空頭嘛
這是空頭下跌的缺口
已經走一大段了 對不對
那這空頭下跌
你看這個是不叫集跌
每天跌
所以這是空頭的末跌段
如果在空頭來說
這個就接近缺口了
最後一個
因為它不再起跌嘛
要走多了對不對
如果是盤整的
這個就叫突破
跌破突破缺口
可是他已經跌到下面來了
你又出來一個缺口
那這個缺口就容易形成
捷徑缺口
他容易形成捷徑缺口
可是如果他跌得更深
他可能也是一個中繼缺口而已
好 那我們再來看
現在跌到這一波
他要反彈了
結果他來了一個缺口
那這個跳空缺口
是不是反彈的力道就會很強
因為他是缺口
他等於是底部向上的一個缺口
他要往上彈
那這個缺口因為是空頭反彈
我們不能做多嘛
可是他會告訴你
你這邊是不是做空了
你趕快補啊
他用缺口來反彈
那這個反彈就會很強
那你不補 你看全部都完了
好 所以老師
這個還不能算是突破缺口
對不對 不算
他只是一個反彈的缺口而已
他只是一個反彈的缺口
他告訴你我要反彈
而且後面會強力反彈
好 反彈完了
現在這個是反彈
然後開始打底了 對不對
那這邊再打底
各位看到又出現一個缺口
那這個缺口我們其實是多頭
為什麼 這邊有反彈
這邊叫回檔 這邊叫上漲
所以這裡就底底高 頭頭高
這是一個多頭
所以形態出現了
就是頭高嘛
然後底底高
因此這個缺口
老師認為是突破缺口
這是多頭確認的缺口
從這裡以後你就要做多了
你就開始做多了
好 那我們這樣子
當然你就按照做多嘛
上漲回檔
然後這裡走完了
你會發現這裡又出現了
一個跳空缺口
而且也是一樣 有大量 有長紅
那這裡你看是不是走了一波了
走了一波 主力又開始用
跳空缺口供
那代表還要再供一波
接著說後面還有一段
也還會有一段可以做到的
這個幅度
那這個我們就叫逃逸缺口
那逃逸缺口你為什麼說
這個是不適接近呢
對 我也是想問 都那麼大一段了
為什麼他是陶毅老師怎麼判斷
因為你這個缺口 你看後面
他就沒有再回來
他沒有把缺口補掉
所以這個缺口沒有補掉
都表示後面
如果他又出現了突破缺口
他就會再漲一波
老師 那如果我們不知道後面
我看到缺口說該怎麼辦
那就看趨勢
各位不要忘囉
你在進場在哪裡進
大家複習一下
回後買上漲 在這裡買
那這裡出現跳躬缺口
不要不要買 好
我不知道它是什麼
不要買啊
因為這不是你進場的位置啊
你進場不會在高檔 我只能在這邊
就對了 對啊
這邊我不確定它是什麼缺口
除非你這個挑剔缺口是第一根
你就可以買 好
它不至第一根
它在第二根第三根喔 對
所以你就不能最高 好
看著它就好了 但是你可以觀察
這個缺口的支撐
如果它沒有跌破
都代表這個股市很強
因為我出了缺口都沒有回來
我就沒有補嘛 對
所以你回來以後
如果做操作
你在這裡買短線是不是就賣了
跌破五均
因為要挺順
賣了以後就看缺口
如果缺口沒有補
後面又來了
這個叫回後買上漲
也回後買上漲
然後上漲之後跌破五均
然後回後買上漲
那你在這裡要賣
因為這裡頭頭低
其實不好做
頭頭低 這你不好做
那頭頭低沒關係
他回檔這個缺口有支撐
那這裡又開始抵抵高
所以你抵抵高嘛
那請問這一根是不是就變成突破了
所以這裡空
這裡變
這是壓力線突破
所以這是多頭
所以你這裡又可以做了
我們上一集就是教支撐壓力
大家可以去學的在畫一下
這個壓力破了
然後抵抵高 頭頭高
你再度進場
因為它轉多了
那這個缺口只是告訴你
我一直都沒有被
跌破 沒有跌破
所以我有支撐
有支撐的喔
有支撐在網上再漲
對
好 這裡各位又看到了
一個長紅 兩個長紅
三個長紅 哇 又出來一個缺口
這裡又跑出來一個缺口
那這個缺口
第二天 第三天
你就看到骨架就疊了
要小心了
這個缺口容易變成捷徑缺口
老師都講容易變成的原因是
如果他在攻
那他還是一個中介缺口
他又是一個中介缺口
那現在可以可以疊下來
這個缺口就被補掉了
所以這你就變捷徑缺口
那實際上我們在前面
各位也回想一下
這個骨架從哪邊長的
16塊
16塊左右
這你呢
這邊已經31 2塊了
還長到34塊了
這個長了一倍了
對
骨架長到一倍
你這個地方
尤其後面叫脊長
紅K 紅K 紅K放量
跳空缺口
三天以內不能回來
一回來它就會變捷徑缺口
那既然這是多頭的
最後一個缺口
所以後面就容易轉成空頭
所以你再做多要小心
不過就趕快跑
因為你這裡有個缺口被補掉了
這邊這個黑黑已經把它補了
所以你再買
等於說跌破了這個缺口的位置
它就是等於補掉的意思
被補掉了
這個缺口已經補掉了
所以這個就變捷徑缺口
所以捷徑缺口有幾個特性
第一個就是爆大量
爆大量
第二個在高檔
第三個三天把它補掉
三天把缺口疊破掉了對不對
對 疊破掉了
那這個就是捷徑缺口
那出現捷徑缺口
後面就不可以再看到頭頭疊了
它就變空頭了
它就會轉空了
它後面就
所以你就準備彈後空下疊了
後面就開始轉成空頭
如果按照這一張的話
老師我覺得對我來說
一一是在這個地方
如果我做空我要趕快回補
對 這邊是最好的買鏡子
對 這邊是起掌
起掌點最好
但是這中間我就很害怕了
因為我可能無法判斷
這中間你就按照紀律做
對
我常常講我們就按照紀律
我們講說盤整你就離開嘛
對
對不對 所以你盤整就離開嘛
所以這個地方也會小賠
然後你就要等喔
你就不能隨便進行
因為它不是多嘛
你就一直等
等到它變多 你再做
所以最後一波你還是有賺
好
這個地方還是有賺錢
所以總之我造華先學這個
我先認突破缺口
萬無一失
尤其是低檔的反彈
對
這個反彈是用跳躬缺口
你的空單要趕快補
好 所以老師我們先瞭解
四個缺口不同的名字
其實剛剛有講
他的缺口會預測未來的走勢
沒錯
對不對 我們來預測一下好不好
我們來看一下
缺口怎麼來預測
缺口最重要
各位就去注意一下
第一個叫趨勢
你在多領面的缺口還是空裡面
對 多頭向上還是多頭向下
是
那第二個是位置
就是我們剛才那一張
那一張有四個不同的位置
各種不同的位置
那第三個缺口的成交量
搭配成交量來看
因為成交量會影響這個缺口的力量
所以缺口也有大小
越大的缺口力量越大
對 剛剛有講過
所以各位想
掌庭板是不是最強
掌庭板那個缺口就超大
你看那個標股都頂著頂
所以這個股票最強
那跌停板就最弱
所以碰到這種就要特別小心
好 那第二個就是
這個缺口的成交量越大
力量就越大
所以你要判斷一個缺口
力量夠不夠大
你就用這兩個去看
看缺口的大小跟乘腰量的大小
所以今天老師要告訴我們
什麼樣的缺口容易漲
什麼樣的缺口容易跌
這兩個位置的缺口就很容易漲
好 我們在剛才有講
多頭回後回檔囉
對
回檔了是不是
它又開始攻了
那這你攻大量跳空缺口
所以這你最容易漲
所以這個地方
本來就是我們要買的嘛
所以你在這裡趕快進場
所以形態上面是多頭
旗掌點的位置 旗掌點
這時候量放大
向上跳空缺口
是一個非常好的進場點
這個就表示強勢
它很容易連續就拉了
那第二個我們在多頭
是不是第二個買點
就叫盤整的突破
那突破它是用跳空的
那比剛才我們講
長紅突破要強啊
對不對 長紅突破我們已經可以買了
那你用跳空是不是更強
所以這個位置也是會繼續
所以是一個突破盤整區放量
跳空的缺口往上也很強
所以這兩個看到都要進場
那第三個就是過壓力的
我前面有個大量黑K
其實我們在講
你如果量不夠大
這個都不太容易過
因為它是壓力
可是你會發現
它居然用跳空的過
這個一樣支撐壓力線
我們上一集有教大家怎麼畫
那基本上這個壓力
就很容易骨架到
他就被壓下去
就會壓下來 大家壓下去對不對
但是沒想到突破還跳空
那就厲害囉
那就是主力
他就是用跳空的告訴你
我一次就給他過了
我表態了 我要讓你突破壓力
所以如果到壓力
第二天開盤就跳空
你就要趕快注意一下
這個主力 這個壓力
今天要過了
他今天要過
那今天要過這個地方
實際上這個是可以買的
你今天可以進場
表示他壓力過了
然後還會繼續上漲
所以你看到了這個位置
跟這個位置都是很容易漲
很容易漲 勝率比較高的對不對
對 勝率比較高的
好 我們來舉個例子來看
大家就知道了
股票我們來看看
這是不是黑K跌下來了
沒錯
跌下來了
月線把它撐著在這邊整理
然後這裡又爆了一個黑K
那應該要跌了吧
對
它沒有跌 紅K上來囉
可是你上來不太敢買嘛
當然啦 因為黑K壓
這個也是壓
這邊還有一個壓力嘛 對不對
對你很多壓壓
主力第二天用跳空的過了
像撐桿跳 跳高
所以你第一天沒有買
你第二天還可以買
因為他把這個壓力過了
所以你買了他就拉了
它是一個表態的動作
對 因為他把前面的黑黑的壓力過了
基本上第二天還會再找
都很容易過
突破壓力 跳空缺口
一定要買
再來是疊的要小心
容易疊就做空
這個就是我們剛剛講的
我們捷律缺口
也碰到捷徑缺口
這個捷徑缺口大量紅K
結果第二天就不漲了
你要小心
這個時候缺口一補他就下來了
剛剛我們其實在那個四個位置
也有講
他也是在波段的高點
又跳空往上漲放量
過兩天不但跌
還把缺口給補起來了
那這個股票就會容易漲
空頭走勢
在這種位置
還有剛才的反彈位置
都是告訴你這個做多的
請你趕快賣
否則他就要回到原點
他就很容易疊回來
所以他是很容易疊的
那如果我做空
是不是在補調這一天開始做空呢
這個做空做歷史
那我剛剛有講說
如果前面幾集
大家都看得很熟練的話
這幾個位置
都是做隔日沖的好位置
隔日沖的好
因為他第二天還未疊
所以你第二天隔日沖都很好做
你都很容易做到
所以老師上的課是互相融會冠中的
每一集都有交叉運用
要好好學
所以大家也可以多看幾遍
然後融會貫通一下
那這個也是我今天碰到壓是黑的嘛
那黑的如果要過
明天就開高跳空嘛
可是它是開低的
所以開低就會下來
所以第二天如果開一個
向下的跳空就都就會下來
所以如果你遇到壓力是黑一黑
那你第二天就看它怎麼開盤
我們講開盤價也很重要
第二天如果是開低走低
你又可以做當充
是
當充做空
ok好
所以我們講的這些關鍵位置
如果你又很熟練K線的變化
那現在再加上缺口
你又可以找到一個做多做空的
當充的位置
當充的好方向
像剛剛這一張的話是
如果突破站上是好買點
對
但如果突破不了還往下
那就又可以再做空了
而且老師說是當充或隔日床
因為當充沒關係
他當天疊下去你就補回來
就補回來就好了
就那個
好
好 我們來處理看看囉
是不是真的是這樣呢
這是向上再調空缺口
結果它是一個黑的
所以它就很容易回來
回來之後上漲
所以你出現了大量的
大量的跳空缺口
可是收的時候黑一黑
黑一黑第二天不能開低
開低就會凋
所以第二天一開
又出了一個缺口
那這個缺口就會往下了
這個缺口會往上
這個缺口就會往下
那這個缺口往下的時候
各位就看到這個下降的缺口
這個第二天疊嘛
所以你要趕快走
因為這邊是向上
那這個是捷徑缺口
所以這一個就是所謂的捷徑缺口
然後他有符合老師講
疊下來還把它補掉了
才兩天
他就把它補
所以這個就是捷徑缺口
捷徑缺口他就會回到原點
他又回來了
回到你的旗展的位置
OK
所以這個向下的跳空缺口
就要特別注意
因為你高檔有爆亮
這個黑K有爆亮
所以第二天一開低
他就很容易殺
很容易殺
再來剛剛我們有看到
有一個缺口
不是突破
他叫反彈
所以我們還有反彈的
剛才我們一路缺口的最低點
那個就是反彈
反彈這邊出現一個跳空缺口
他就容易轉槍
那這個是給誰作用的
給你作空的 趕快補
因為他一彈就要彈到這上面來
所以我們就趕快補
那我空手的
我看到主力那麼強的反彈
所以這你容易打底
這邊就容易打底了
連續下跌爆亮
突然往上漲
還出現缺口
特別留意 空單一定要補
空單趕快回補
不見得要做多
但做多的要回補
然後不然你就被割到了
那做多的就等一等
等他後面打底
等他
那另外一個就是反過來了
我下跌碰到支撐
然後出現紙叠的訊號
那第二天如果一出現跳工缺口
他就會攻
他這等於支撐很有撐 很有效
而且主力是大量強力的表態
我這邊把它撐住了
我不讓它叠
那這樣當然這個位置
就很容易上漲
但這個是因為這邊是空
所以你這也是跟這個一樣
再搶反彈
你可以去做搶反彈
反彈就做隔日衝
或者是做明天的當衝
做短線就對了
短線你就很容易做到
老師也是一樣舉個例子
反彈的跳空缺口
好 那這裡黑K是不是有大量
然後就不疊了嘛
不疊了
後面就不疊了
表示這裡有直升
可是他因為是個空頭
加上均線還有壓
所以他彈一彈彈一彈又下來了
對不對
他因為這個季線都沒有克服
那下來了之後
現在要碰到這個直升
他碰到這個直升
這裡是不是有紅的 直疊囉
所以第二天你可以準備了
他一開高他就會上來
那這一開高就留了一個
向上的跳弓缺口
實際上這個向上的跳弓缺口
就很容易把這個高點過
那如果各位在前面
有一直看節目你就會知道
這個高點一過就會轉成多頭
要突破啦 還是要站上去對不對
還是要站上去 突破他就會變多
但是如果沒有突破
下面的支撐很強
因為這是跳弓缺口
這有量喔
這個大概不容易跌了
你也不要做空了
他容易在這裡盤底了
好
所以我們又要來告訴大家
今天的跳空缺口
趙華上了渣渣實實的一堂課
因為趙華以前買股票
就跟老師講說只要均線多拍
然後站上哪裡
KD交叉黃金什麼的
但是我從來沒有去管缺口
不缺口
看來趙華對強事股跟弱勢股
好像沒有那麼的在意
但是上完今天這堂課
我學會了
可是大家在課程中有沒有發現呢
老師有畫什麼
那個缺口也是有大小的有沒有
然後那個缺口其實事實上
它也會有壓力跟支撐喔
那我們上一集雖然有講壓力跟支撐
但是並沒有講到缺口
怎麼看壓力跟支撐
那這個會留給什麼呢
會留給我們精英班的好朋友喔
所以我們今天的理財大連繡
標古在線等教你跳空缺口
有沒有學起來呢
如果你是想要進階學習的
趕快趕快
加入我們的精英班
我們現在要來教你畫喔
這個缺口的壓力支撐
在哪裡了
那我們今天的理財單
就到這邊了
我們下次再見囉
Bye Bye